this question was submitted by a member
of the electrical and electronics
engineers magnetics community the
question is will spin transfer torque
research be awarded a nobel prize in the
future a spinto sweat dog this fear of
his sir she is very active today and
very exciting ok you can do many things
with spin transfer you can switch the
magnetization of a magnet with
electrical currents these will be used
for example in the next generation of em
ha the STT spin prosthetic arms and
certainly this will have a strong impact
on in electronics this can be used also
to generate oscillation in the high
frequency hinge certainly with many
applications in telecommunications so
this is a very exciting field we in this
laboratory are working a lot in this
field in particular on generation of
microwaves so for a Nobel Prize I don't
know I don't know maybe it's a little
too close from the beginning of the
spintronics that is from GMO and GMO and
so but it would be great if a Nobel
Prize is given for this the ocean of
inertia